qué análisis hace de este resultado
porque la mayoría de los chilenos
optaron por el rechazo de la nueva
constitución
bueno yo creo que es todo el resultado
todo muy marcado por el plebiscito de
entrado de un 80 por ciento de las
personas que hicieron una nueva
constitución y la elección luego de los
constituyentes que estuvo más bien
marcada con un alto en apoyo a los
independientes de los movimientos
sociales eso marcó la es narrativa y el
trabajo de locomoción constituyente en
general muy separada de la política
tradicional de las preocupaciones
tradicionales de los partidos políticos
más bien hacia una propuesta que quizás
un poco más
extremista o más hacia la izquierda de
lo que hubiese entendido la política o
el congreso en general lo que además
tuvo muchas controversias dentro de la
convención algunos convencionales o
algunos
constituyentes no tuvieron no estuvieron
a la altura también creo yo y esto
terminó aceptando la propuesta que yo
creo que en términos generales responde
a las demandas sociales pero que para
muchas personas fue difícil separar el
autor de la obra tal mismo claro y
cuáles considera usted que han sido
quizás los puntos que generaron mayor
controversia o rechazo entre los
ciudadanos
yo creo que has llegado para quedarse
por ejemplo la paridad o el rol del
estado frente a el cuidado del medio
ambiente pero hay otros temas que quizás
no hemos procesado completamente
culturalmente como la plurinacional y
labor de conocimiento de pueblos
indígenas si bien se avanzó en eso y hoy
día es muy probable que cualquier nuevo
diseño institucional incluya más que la
situación actual a los pueblos
originarios la declaración de la
plurinacionalidad y todas las normas
asociadas eso creo que fue una de las
cosas que también me asustaron un poco a
la ciudadanía que también
se informó a través de un proceso que
también estuvo muy marcado por una
desinformación y una complejidad general
de informar un texto constitucional de
muchísimas normas y muchísimos temas
valentina el presidente gabriel boric ya
dijo recientemente que dará continuidad
al proceso constituyente dijo además que
convocó a representantes tanto del
congreso como de la sociedad civil para
este mismo lunes qué etapa se abre ahora
y que podemos esperar
yo creo que para una audiencia
internacional lo más complejo de
entender es que los chilenos aún
queremos una nueva constitución todos
los polis los partidos políticos han
declarado expresamente que la
constitución vigente está políticamente
muerta y que este rechazo fue
principalmente en específico a esta
propuesta nueva constitución y de ahí
nace esta propuesta del presidente
gabriel boric de continuar esto no sólo
un anhelo de él sino que es un anhelo
bastante compartido y transversal
incluso las campañas de rechazo el
eslogan era rechazamos esta propuesta
así que ahora él está el piso para un
acuerdo transversal obviamente con este
desarrollo este resultado tan
contundente las negociaciones podrán
estar un poco más tensa de lo que
inicialmente se esperaba pero pero la
gran mayoría de creo que tiene la fe de
que el presidente tiene la capacidad de
convocar a todos los sectores políticos
en este anhelo como decía compartido de
que chile aún necesita una nueva
constitución ahora barcina para muchos
este plebiscito fue además una
manifestación de aprobación y de rechazo
no sólo la constitución sino al gobierno
del propio gabriel boric coincide usted
con esta postura y de ser así a qué
atribuye este evaluación negativa de la
gestión del presidente
bueno yo creo que se mezclan muchas
cosas y luego las democracia en general
las leyes son complicadas más complejas
y todos los presidentes en los últimos
años desde la vuelta a la democracia en
chile han tendido a una aprobación a la
baja luego de iniciar su mandato si
viene el presidente bonita ha bajado
contundentemente no es de los
presidentes que más ha bajado así que
también hay matices pero sí es claro que
el presidente era un un abierto
[Música]
es fan de esta de esta propuesta una
constitución era abiertamente
explícitamente alguien que llamaba a
aprobar este texto por lo tanto este es
un escenario complejo para su para su
gobierno pero no se encuentra tampoco
necesariamente en el peor escenario
político él sigue teniendo un liderazgo
muy respetado por todos los sectores
políticos
especialmente por los sectores que
también en congreso y por lo tanto por
eso también creo que si bien es un
escenario complejo y más complejo de lo
que ellos mismos tenían proyectado aún
el piso político para que él sea capaz
de convocar estos acuerdos transversales